las fuerzas rusas lanzaron anoche un
nuevo ataque sobre Ucrania especialmente
sobre la ciudad de kiev y también en la
ciudad de odesa la tercera ciudad del
país esto viene siendo frecuente
especialmente en los últimos días
previos a ese 9 de mayo cuando se
conmemora La derrota de la Alemania nazi
y se llevó a cabo ese día de la Victoria
Moscú con ese gran desfile planeado para
mañana en la plaza roja pero también
esto viene dándose previo a esa
contraofensiva que planean iniciar las
fuerzas ucranianas en los próximos días
o semanas estamos a la espera de que la
altos militares ucranianos den la orden
pero desde hace ya bastantes días los
rusos vienen lanzando ataques contra
instalaciones civiles pero también
militares en el país lo que se conoce es
que lanzaron al menos 35 drones
kamikazes de fabricación de ellos sobre
kiev que venían desde diferentes
direcciones los treinta Fueron
interceptados por la defensa antiaérea
ucraniana pero tiene consecuencias
bastante lamentables para la población
civil uno de ellos cuando fue atacado
los restos cayó en este edificio que
está a mis espaldas al menos cinco
personas habrían quedado heridas y otros
carros alrededor habrían quedado
destruidos o calcinados otro gran ataque
también se dio en esa ciudad de Odessa
donde al menos ocho misiles alcanzaron
diferentes edificaciones especialmente
una fábrica de alimentos donde se
aprendió un gran fuego y también fue
atacado con diferentes ataques aéreos
esto también Se repitió en otras
ciudades como harkie de Nitro o también
en gersón que viene siendo atacada con
gran intensidad en los últimos días y se
esperan mayores ataques previos a mañana
y previos a esta contraofensiva que
tanto esperan los ucranianos